and the Oscar goes to excuse me Glen
Hansard Sally for me
nomination for dilemma
and
Thanks yeah grab milla milla Margot's
and this is amazing what are we doing
here this is mad air we may just film
two years ago where we shot on two
handycams took us three weeks to make we
made it for home to ground we'd never
thought we'd ever come into a room like
this and be in front of you people it's
been an amazing thing and thanks for
taking this film seriously alia it means
a lot to us thanks the Academy thanks to
all the people have helped us to know
who they are we don't need to say them
this is amazing make art make art yeah
thanks
Wow
that guy is so arrogant
yeah you don't you feel just wonderful
that's just such a beautiful song that
really is a wonderful moment for them a
wonderful nice to see you again I just
wanted to do something very quickly the
winners of best song marquetta or Globa
didn't get a chance to say thank you so
I just wanted to bring around here again
real quick just to get a chance to do
you want to come out real quick I'm
sorry
there you go enjoy your moment
hi everyone I just want to thank you so
much and this is such a big deal not
only for us but for all other
independent musicians and artists that
spend most of their time struggling and
it is the fact that we're standing here
tonight the fact that was able to hold
this is just it's just a proof that no
matter how far out your dreams are it's
possible and you know fair play to those
who dare to dream and don't give up and
this song was written from a perspective
of hope and hope at the end of the day
connects us all no matter how different
we are and so thank you so much who
helped us along the way thank you
you